Donald you know is great at at the
one-liners but he's a chaos candidate
and he'd be a chaos president he said
that very simply because he has failed
in this campaign it's been a total
disaster I want to talk to the audience
at home for a second if your eyes are
glazing over like mine this is what it's
like to be on the floor of the United
States Senate why did we miss the San
Bernardino coupled we were using the
wrong algorithms Isis is using the
internet better than we are using the
internet and it was our idea Marco has
has continued these attacks and he knows
they're not true so little bit again no
not you're trying to build up your
enemies yeah but it's not one of the
time you're not gonna be able to insult
your way to the presidency who would be
I just can't imagine somebody booing
these are people that want to kill us
folks bring back the warrior class
Petraeus McChrystal mattis if our
military experts say we need boots
underground we should put boots on the
ground it's like a purple unicorn they
never exist these moderate rebels end up
being jihadists I wish it was spent
right here in the United States on our
schools hospitals roads airports and
everything else that are all falling
apart frankly it's time that we punched
the Russians in the nose maybe because
I'm from New Jersey I just have this
kind of plain language hang up I think
when we think about the judgment of
someone who might want world war three
we might think about someone who might
shut down a bridge because they don't
like their friends they don't want to
they want to get a Democrat it's very
sad that CNN leads Jeb Bush governor
Bush down a road by starting off
virtually all of the questions mr. Trump
this mr. I think it's very sad you know
there was a time for choosing as Reagan
put it where there was a battle over
amnesty and and some chose like senator
Rubio to stand with Barack Obama and
Chuck Schumer and support a massive
amnesty plan but we will build a wall
that works and i'll get Donald Trump to
pay for it I'll build
just this weekend you said senator Cruz
is not qualified to be president because
he doesn't have the right temperament
and acted like a maniac when he arrived
in the Senate but last month you said
you were opening open to naming senator
Cruz as you're running me I did so why
would you be willing to put somebody it
was a maniac one hardly gotten to know
him over the last three or four days he
is a wonderful temperament he's just
fine don't worry about you have not been
willing to attack mr. Trump in public
but you did mention his judgment in
having control of America's nuclear
arsenal during a private meeting with
supporters why are you willing to say
things about him in private and not in
public what I'm saying Dan is that is a
judgment for every voter to make what i
can tell you is all nine of the people
here would make an infinitely better
commander-in-chief than Barack Obama or
Hillary Clinton are you ready to
reassure Republicans tonight that you
will run as a Republican and abide by
the decision of the Republicans I really
am